[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Christophe I work at Facebook I'm an
engineering manager on the JavaScript
tools team in London and today I'm going
to talk about building high quality
JavaScript tools because at Facebook we
learned that we need to continuously
invest into our developer experience and
to make we need to make tools delightful
and I'd like to show you how we apply
the product mindset to Jess our
JavaScript testing framework that aims
to make testing painless and I want to
show you how we work with the JavaScript
community to rebuild it I'm a quick show
of hands who has heard of Jess okay
that's a lot of people who is using Jess
oh that's great okay awesome if you're
not using it yes yes I'll try to
convince you if you're already using it
then I'll make you want to use it more
so unfortunately JavaScript testing with
Jess wasn't quite as painless as we
wanted it to be this story has some dark
moments and you know in in open-source
nobody was starting to adopt Jess you
know and I'm not making this up this is
an actual tweet about Jess from about
two years ago this is not something you
ever want to hear about a project you
know we knew we had some work to do and
at Facebook it wasn't that much better
just worked okay is a tool to you know
write tests for your JavaScript
applications but here's the thing in
this in this oil painting you can see a
party going on in the background and
this gesture he's just so gloomy and sad
you know and this is literally the
experience that people had at Facebook
when they were dealing with JavaScript
testing
everybody was super excited about
building react applications but we found
that nobody was actually writing any
test because Java JavaScript testing
with just wasn't great so you know we
decided to rebuild tests and to turn
that sad gesture into a happy one but
you might be asking yourself you know
hold on you know do we even need testing
you know like who cares maybe we don't
even need it you know
we realized that Jess isn't great but
maybe we can get by without any testing
but of course testing is an important
part of the engineering process it
significantly influences engineering
behavior and we learned that people
write code differently with or without a
test framework and to be specific about
this
it helps by enabling a faster iterative
development cycle it makes sure you have
fewer bugs in your applications and you
can make releases more often so when we
go on to improve testing we can look at
it as we would at any product you know
like what do you do with it and how can
we make that experience better
so for Jess it's about what you want
when you're running tests the test
runner and what do you want when you're
writing tests for running tests I want
feedback as quickly as possible it
should be instant it should give me
signal about failure failing and passing
tests immediately and for writing tests
I want the best possible testing ideas
available to me but also I want to have
great documentation so that I can learn
how to write effective tests and as we
develop these requirements we can come
up with three things one of them is
performance
the other one is feature features and
then adoptability
all three of these requirements they're
equally important you know you need to
fulfill all of them at the same time to
make a successful product for example if
you're building the most feature-rich
test runner but then it's really really
slow
nobody's going to adopt it and at the
same time if you're building a really
really fast test runner with no features
again nobody will adopt it and then also
of course if you're building the most
amazing test Runner but nobody's using
it and
what's the point of all of this so I
gave you a bunch of buzzwords but if we
peel back this product layer a little
bit and look at emoji and what it was
like as an engineer working on this this
was really really hard and painful you
know we had something that didn't work
well and we had to figure out how to fix
it and I kind of came up with these
three things that kind of help if you
think about this that does help you on
this like process to make something
great
it's fix rewrites and polish it's kind
of like FRP functional reactive
programming but this one is fixed
rewrites in Polish and let me take you
through this journey by focusing on the
three major requirements and the first
one is performance performance at scale
is the most important feature actually
at Facebook we realized that we had
thousands of existing test suites and
this low test runner so we decided to
fix that and naturally your instincts
would tell you okay this is not great
let's just dump it let's just build a
new thing and replace the old thing but
we had so many tests at Facebook that we
couldn't do that and then also from past
experience we learned that that big
rewrite significantly take longer than
anticipated and sometimes they don't
even work out at all so we decided to
improve our testing framework by
explicitly not rewriting the whole thing
but by making major changes
incrementally in small parts of the
framework itself and I want to stress
that it's often enough to make 1%
improvements over time you know here's a
part of the system that we rewrote where
it really helped internally at Facebook
we have thousands of test files and tens
of thousands of modules you know we we
have a lot of information that we need
to keep track of to run tests not just
which tests are associated with which
modules it's also which modules are
associated with which tests so that we
can run their correct tests when files
are changing so we rebuild a system that
analyzes the entire file system and then
extract metadata from all the files that
we care about and then also tracks
dependencies for example in tests when
you're using it and you're changing the
store file up there
just you'll know that it only needs to
run the store test instead of all the
thousands of test files that you might
have
we also rewrote the system that
paralyzes test runs across worker
processes in your on your machine by you
looking at data from previous test runs
that makes just a lot faster and then as
I told you we made many small
improvements over time we changed how we
cache transformed files to be more
effective we improved our module
resolution algorithm that we have ingest
and also we upgraded third-party
libraries to better alternatives because
we haven't you know like work that just
for a while and we just figured out what
alternatives have been created since
then so now that we have performance in
a good state and we can run just with
tens of thousands of test files we need
to look at features just comes with
dozens of awesome features out of the
box but today I'll only focus on three
of them first one is the improved output
then we'll talk about this immersive
watch mode that like sucks you into jest
and you can adjust a there and and it's
an awesome unit testing experience and
then we'll also talk briefly about this
natural assertion so let's focus on the
improve the output first this is what
just used to look like
there were log messages all over stack
traces that didn't matter and you have
like a failing assertion you're trying
to compare two objects and you have no
idea what's going on right we realized
that just was kind of okay when test for
passing but the value of a test
framework is to actually give you signal
about failing tests and helping you
resolve those issues so we just
completely rewrote the assertion library
with this product mindset to figure out
what do engineers wants to see when a
test is failing
for example we color coded everything so
that you know what is green what is red
and then also we're showing a diff when
two objects don't match up so you know
exactly what's going on the exciting
thing about this is that we give just
its own identity when you see a
screenshot of a test framework you
instantly know it's just
that's awesome we also have this
concurrent runner it's beautiful it
shows you exactly which test is running
right now what the status of the test
run is and it even shows you how long
the test run is likely going to take
based on previous test runs
what's also awesome is that just
actually takes a note when a test is
sailing and the next time you run it it
actually runs the failed test first to
give you signal about those testing
immediately because that's what you
probably care about the most at that
point in time the next I want to talk
about the immersive watch mode this one
is really cool let's take a quick look
it just runs tests really quickly shows
you what's happening and then what you
can do with it so when you start it up
you just call it with dash dash watch
and then you can press P for example for
this pattern mode and then you have this
amazing type-ahead where you you just
like type in which test you want to run
and you can select it from a drop-down
because just knows everything about your
system your project and knows exactly
which tests you you have in the next
version of just we we extend the does
this a little bit further you even have
like keyboard navigation in this and I'm
talking about a CLI tool but it's all
about you know beautiful CLI tools and a
great developer experience in them and
then finally I want to talk about
snapshots have you ever written an
assertion like this in any test
framework and you don't know exactly
what you're going to put there in your
test you don't know exactly what the
output of your function is it happens
quite often right and then we do what we
always do which is comment out this
assertion and then we log the value and
we take that and we put it back into our
test and we're like okay we're done here
and then you know judging from the faces
that I see a bunch of urs guilty of
doing business I am right so we decided
to make this a bit easier because we
found that a lot of people weren't even
writing tests for a lot of code that
could benefit from this so we introduced
this new a
called too much a snapshot mm-hmm here
I'll show you how it works the first
time it's really simple when you're
using it you'll inspect the output of
your code and then just we'll just
record it as a snapshot in a snapshot
file the next time you're running this
test just will compare the snapshot with
the output of your code in this example
we are changing the link of a react
component from facebook.com to
instagram.com and then just will yell at
you and say hey look something in your
system has changed if this is
intentional or not and then if you
decide yes that is actually changed I
wanted to make you can pass in the flag
to update all the snapshots all right
and one of you might be looking at me
like now hold on Kristoff you know what
are we doing here this is not testing at
all
right but we found that it's actually a
lot better to be able to create a bunch
of these kind of tests for regression
testing for example really quickly
instead of just waiting until that code
hits production and that is the first
time anybody's ever running that code
right so it's preventing a lot of a lot
of issues for people and snapshots I
want to be clear about that they don't
replace conventional testing or all the
other assertions it's just an addition
on top of those it's just one assertion
among like 20 or 30 or however many
shipped with Jess the choice is not
between chapt a snapshot testing and
utter assertion assertions the choice is
between snapshot testing or no testing
at all there are projects like prepare
the JavaScript for murder where I'm
confident it wouldn't exist in its
current form if it weren't for snapshot
testing it just couldn't have moved as
quickly and then if you know by now
because I told you just is a great test
runner it can do everything you know
like this gesture in this photo it just
takes care of everything it's amazing
which brings me to a really exciting
announcement it's actually really big
but then in the end it's kind
unimpressive you know I'm going to show
you one more feature have you ever found
yourself like juggling multiple projects
on one
and you have like a really hard time
imagine you're building react front ends
and the node.js back-end or you're
working at Facebook you having a
terrible day you're trying to to debug a
bunch of projects at the same time and
you have like a bunch of test runs in a
bunch of different projects and that's
not really fun so we taught Jess how to
juggle and we calling this the multi
project runner which leads me that is
incredibly unimpressive demo in the next
version of Jess just 20 you'll be able
to pass any amount of projects that
you're working on and then it works
something like this you can stay inside
of just all day long it will watch all
your projects at the same time in a
single instance here it's going to be
running a few tests in watch mode I'm
starting it up with a bunch of project
like yarn and Jess and relay and tree
Alex and you can filter all the tests
across all of these projects and for
example here we're deciding to run all
of the tests for react and relay just
hit enter we run all the tests so that's
going to be shipping in the next version
of Jess and finally about features I
want to say that the experience should
be delightful you know I don't want to
fight with my test runner because only
if the experience is an enjoyable
experience will actually make people
want to write more tests so now that we
looked at performance and features we
should also talk a little bit about
adaptability because we spent all of
this time at Facebook to make just
really really good and now it's just we
just want you to give it a try as well
you know how do you get started with
this the great thing about jest is that
we turned it into this zero
configuration test framework you know it
ships with a ton of great features out
of the box and all you need to do is
install it with yarn then you can go on
to write a simple test and then you just
run it it has code coverage built in you
don't need to set anything up for most
projects that will just work we also
managed to bundle chest
with other JavaScript tools to form a
more cohesive development experience if
you're using react native or create
react up you'll get a test setup with
just by default and you don't need to
set anything up this also leads me to
another small announcement and so the
JavaScript tools team in London that
Facebook is also working on yarn um the
the package manager next week we're
going to ship is really really tiny
commands that I'm excited about
it's called yarn create and it's
extendable and you can look at it as
your new entry point to build any
application right so instead of
installing some global CLI you can just
a yarn create reacts ax or yarn create a
react native app and you can build your
own plug-ins for that this is a super
sweet way to get started with something
new these low-friction ways to get
started are great and you might even
start your next project with just right
but that's not good enough we also need
to figure out how can we make just work
may make just work for you when you're
already using when you already have a
big project when you peel back the outer
layer of just you should ideally also
find that things that make sense on its
own and that wasn't always the case so
not long ago Jess was just one big
repository with not much internal
structure so we did something super
obvious we introduced structure by
turning it into one big modular
repository we've actually split up just
into 30 individual packages that can be
reused in many different contexts
we're talking about pulling things apart
from like one big giant things a thing
into many many small packages this
helped with the separation of concerns
between the different modules and it
naturally led us to turning just into a
platform we actually ship all of these
packages to NPM and you can install all
of them individually and use them in
contexts that sometimes don't even have
anything to do with testing they range
from things like a nice mint plug-in to
an editor support plugins to the
snapshot implementation and all the
other low-level modules of just
a lot of them can actually be used
outside of just at Facebook for example
we use this haste map package that
analyzes all your dependencies at
Instagram in react native packager and
also for some of our internal link
plugins the snapshot package has been
adopted by another test runner and by
react UI development libraries like door
ebooks and snap guide is a style goddess
and then the chest validate package is a
tool that can help you for your own
JavaScript tools to make it easier to
set them up and give meaningful error
messages to to the users this has been
adopted and prettier I'll show you just
a quick example of this one because I
think it's kind of cool I'm sure all of
you can agree that with me the
JavaScript tools could be easier to set
up for the first time right so if you
drop in just validate into your own
project you can make it easier for
everybody in this case for example if
you're trying to set up just for the
first time you have a typo in your
configuration will actually yell at you
and that's really easy to set up so
packages led us to consolidate
infrastructure and to share best
practices it's a good case where all the
parts together just is pretty good but
the parts individually they are also
great and about sharing best practices
the way I see it is the more we can
standardize on how we write tests the
easier will be for people to figure out
how to write effective tests and then
the other effect that this separation of
concerns had is that it made the chess
project more hackable and we were able
to build a great open source community
around it for example this is the editor
integration in vs code for jest this is
something that's awesome it gives you
instant feedback and we didn't even
realize that this is something that was
being worked on until it was already
done and we managed to merge the generic
pieces back into Jess so that other IDs
can adopt this and provide a great unit
testing experience in with chest we
managed to add two new core contributors
to Jess who are not working at Facebook
and they're just contributing to just in
their on their own time
I'll show you an example of what that is
so rehalia and Michelle joined the team
something like this so I just created an
issue on our issue tracker and I was
like oh I have this idea we should build
this type of head that I showed you
earlier right and then it's a really
it's a fairly complex feature and then
one day I woke up and rehalia was like
hey I found this really interesting so I
just went ahead and built it and it was
amazing you know and I come back and
like wow this is great you know we
should ship this but we actually need to
rewrite the whole thing to make this
work for you know Facebook's use case
and like here's an example of how you
could do that and then a couple days
later he just came back and he's like
hey you know here's another pull request
I rewrote the whole thing added test
it's awesome you know the chip it and
that was a really great experience and
rehalia did a ton of awesome work for
jest and even presented it at react conf
two months ago and so did dozens of
other people
the Jess project is now approachable and
easy to contribute to by anybody and we
notice that there's there new
contributors to just every week that we
haven't even known about before so
that's awesome
and the contributors and many others
they are now touring the world with
parts at conferences like this one
there's a tutorials blog post books even
written about Jess and finally I feel
like we have new conversations about how
we can simplify testing and write more
tests and I feel like that's really
exciting
one thing that I'm going to ask you the
JavaScript communities we need help with
translations documentation is essential
to teach people how to write tests and
if tests or documentation is not written
in the language that you're most
familiar with it's really hard to get
started so if you have some time if you
speak another language please help us
translate the documentation for tests we
would really appreciate it but that's
still not enough to get people to adopt
Jess we need something more if you have
an existing project and some people
might have seen this light before and
they're catching on to what I'm trying
to do here so I was here about two years
ago and
owns this concept of code mods to the
JavaScript community right it's like the
system of how you can transform entire
code bases to new API right so there is
this project called code mods and
together with J's coach if you can
convert an existing project to just if
you haven't been there at the last J's
comes
here's a small refresher say you have
this test with J's code shift and just
code mode you can automatically convert
this and print all of your files the way
as if you had written them yourself into
your project immediately in a couple of
seconds and I have a short demo of this
so I found this project all I did so far
i ah digest it has a couple hundred
tests and then I just type just code
mods
no not code mutt code mark alright and
then I've looked at the test before we
were converting try and expect and then
I just hit enter and takes a couple of
seconds code modes break down silos
between frameworks they enable you to
move from one framework to other
frameworks in a couple of seconds and
all we need to do now is we run just
that takes a couple of seconds I tested
it before it's a little bit faster than
it was before so you get a nice
performance speed-up that is the wrong
version of test also
I apologize we need we need yarn for
this okay this is going to take a couple
of seconds so this is super exciting you
can just go to a new test runner alright
there's only about 8 sets failing out of
300 so I feel pretty good about this
alright let me just push this I have it
here already I just wanted to send a
quick pull request if my Internet's
working it is not not there it is
all right I'll explain a bit more later
all right we got this
cool the best part of the story is that
jess cosmos was entirely community
driven the project was created by the
community iterated on by the community
and just maintained by the community
this is awesome as a result more than a
hundred companies have told us that they
have adopted just in the last six months
alone some of them are really big some
of them are really small so it's
impossible without code mods we look at
metrics at Facebook the number of tests
people wrote in the last six months has
grown by 35% which is more more than
twice as much as it has grown ever
before when we improved our testing
experience people at Facebook naturally
started writing more tests and after all
this the experience of writing tests
with Jess it's not painful anymore and I
would even say that it's more than just
painless just provide the delightful
JavaScript testing experience it's now a
product that gives confidence to
engineers when they're building software
and not only did we accomplish that we
also made testing fun and exciting and
then finally I've been mentioning just
20 a few times in the last 20 minutes
and I pointed out a bunch of major
features that we're going to ship you
know it's been a while that since we
have made a major release and we worked
really really hard on this
it's the biggest just release that we
have ever made and I was thinking I'm
just going to show and ship this to you
right now we just need to publish it
with yarn and Lerner and then we'll just
tell it out it is going to be a major of
course everything's awesome and then I
need to merge this send another pull
request really quick just one moment all
right sweet
all right that's two pool requests I
think that's enough for today
[Music]
what you've seen today is that building
tools is successful when you look beyond
your own walls and you collaborate with
the wider JavaScript community with just
this was a lesson that we learned the
hard way you know but the best part
about working together is that the best
ideas often come from people who you
don't work with every day you know and
the result is an empowered ecosystem and
better tools that we can turn into
products with a delightful experience
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]